Maybe you’ve noticed that every time we
talk about a new system, we highlight its
importance by saying how you’d die without
it.
Like, without your muscular and skeletal systems
you’d collapse into an inert bag of goo.
Or how if we magically removed your respiratory
or circulatory system, you’d die in a couple
of minutes ‘cause your cells wouldn’t
have oxygen.
That’s because most of our bodies’ systems
are just trying to keep us alive, minute to minute.
But one of those systems doesn’t really care if
you live or die. At least, not until it’s done its job.
It’s how every living thing gets its start,
but it doesn’t really kick in until puberty,
and even then it’s more concerned about
investing in the future than keeping you alive.
When it comes to your reproductive system,
it’s not concerned about you, so much as
it is about your alleles, your genetic code,
and the future of the human species.
Which are no small stakes.
This system includes our primary, internal
sex organs, the gonads -- like testes and
ovaries -- the various sex hormones they secrete,
and the gametes -- the sperm and eggs -- they produce.
It also includes the glands, ducts, external
genitalia, and particular brain parts that help the
gonads and gametes do what they need to do, which
basically is mate, combine alleles, and make babies.
Now, all animals have their own particular
and fascinating anatomical methods for getting
their gametes together, and we could do a
whole course just on that, and never run out
of material, and let me tell you, I would
like to do that.
But while we may seem kinda tame compared
to animals that turn bright red, bite off
penises, or starve themselves for a chance
to breed, our systems are still plenty complex.
In fact, it’s gonna take most of the month
to get through all our various anatomical
parts and hormones, and explain how sexy time,
fertilization, pregnancy, and development
work, starting today with the female anatomy.
And remember, this is nothing to be shy about
-- when we’re talking about sex, we’re
talking about the future of humanity.
So, when we talk about sex, we’re talking
about spreading our alleles around. But when
we visualize sex, what most of what we picture
are our anatomies.
Who has what. And what goes where.
In an anatomical female, that involves the
vulva, which includes the mons pubis over
the pubic bone, and labia majora and labia
minora — the elongated skin folds that surround
the vestibule, which contains both the urethral
and vaginal openings.
Beyond that is the vagina, which I’m sure
you know is how menstrual blood and babies
leave the body, and how sperm gets in.
But, as much as we tend to put all the focus
on the bathing-suit parts, those are only
the genitalia -- the external sexual organs.
And they’re really just a means of getting
gametes together. Reproductively speaking,
they’re the least important parts of the
system.
The ground control of the female reproductive
anatomy -- the place where the orders are
given -- are of course the ovaries. Their main job is
to produce and release female gametes and sex
hormones like estrogen and progesterone.
You’ll remember from biology that gametes
are haploid cells, meaning that they only
have one set of chromosomes, and are formed
by meiosis.
When a sperm fuses with an egg, they make
a diploid cell, which has all the genetic
instructions required to make a baby. And
pretty much everything about how our reproductive
systems work is designed to make that happen.
Each ovary lives inside a fibrous sac that
consists of a layer of connective tissue called
the tunica albuginea, and another layer of
cuboidal epithelial cells called the germinal
epithelium, which is actually part of the
peritoneum that lines the abdominal cavity.
The ovary itself contains a cortex that houses
developing eggs, and a medulla that contains
most of the ovary’s blood vessels and nerves.
But the business of passing on alleles and
saving humanity really begins in the basic
reproductive units in the cortex -- the ovarian
follicles.
These are tiny-sac-like structures that each
hold a single primary oocyte — a sort of
incomplete proto-egg — along with a bunch
of supporting follicle cells around it.
Females are born with essentially all of these
early versions of eggs in all of the primordial
follicles they will ever have -- around 1
million at the time of birth.
But right around birth, the oocytes stop developing
-- they get stuck in the first stage of meiosis.
And they stay that way for years, sometimes
forever.
The actual process of egg creation, or oogenesis,
is delayed until puberty, when the rest of
the body is physically ready to reproduce.
Now, this works differently for us than it
does for some other animals. Like, if you’re
a salmon or a mayfly, then all of your eggs
will mature at once, and then you’ll mate,
reproduce, and usually die, in quick succession.
I mean, people talk about living fast and
dying young, but that -- that’s too fast.
So human eggs mature one-by-one, almost constantly,
doled out so that every month or so, a mature
egg is either fertilized, or dies to make
way for a new egg.
This should all sound familiar if you were
born with female anatomy, or know anyone who
was, because it’s a big part of the well-known
monthly menstrual cycle.
But the truth is, menstruation is only one
part of one cycle.
The menstrual cycle is what happens in the
uterus to prepare for a fertilized egg. The
other cycle, the ovarian cycle, is all about
the maturation of the follicle and egg, and
it’s actually what drives the menstrual
cycle.
Every day, even before birth, a bunch of follicles
will begin a process of maturation, very slowly
morphing from primordial follicles into what’s
known as late-tertiary follicles, which are
the ones that will support a fully developed
egg.
This process takes 375 days.
But out of that bunch of follicles -- usually
about 20 or so -- only one follicle will end
up supporting a single, mature egg. The rest
won’t get the hormonal boost they need to
bring the egg to completion. This is what
happens to the one that start maturing before
puberty, for example, so they undergo atresia,
a kind of programmed self- destruction.
And because I keep mentioning puberty, which
you’ve probably been through yourself, it
should come as no surprise that all of this
activity is regulated by sex hormones.
Starting around puberty, the hypothalamus
and pituitary set up two concurrent cycles
-- the ovarian cycle in the ovaries, which
ripens eggs and secretes sex hormones, and
the menstrual, or the uterine cycle, which
prepares the uterus to capture and nourish
any mature, fertilized eggs.
When puberty begins the hypothalamus starts up the
ovarian cycle by secreting gonadotropin-releasing
hormone about once a month. This is a sex
hormone that stimulates the anterior pituitary
to release two more hormones: follicle-stimulating
hormone -- you’ll often hear it called FSH
-- and luteinizing hormone, or LH.
The follicle-stimulating hormone lives up
to its name by stimulating the growth of a
follicle -- but only one: the one that happens
to be furthest along in development at the time.
The FSH drives that one lucky follicle to
keep growing, by triggering the follicle itself
to secrete its own estrogen hormones, which
locally signal the follicle to mature even more.
That surge of follicle-secreted estrogen then
ends up stimulating the pituitary to secrete
another pulse of luteinizing hormone to finish
the job.
The LH gets to work on the oocyte that’s
been dormant inside the follicle, and triggers
it to finally start dividing again -- getting it to
complete meiosis I and move on to metaphase II.
This whole process takes about 14 days, at
the end of which, the follicle -- which is
now mature -- pushes up against the ovary
wall, ruptures, and, with the help of enzymes,
breaches the wall and ejects a single, now
mature, oocyte.
Congratulations. You’ve just ovulated.
The damaged follicle now slows its estrogen
production while morphing into a different
structure, called the corpus luteum, which
eventually degenerates.
But first it releases a final hormonal swan
song -- a bunch of progesterone, a little
estrogen, and some inhibin -- that together
stop the release of FSH and LH.
They also prepare the uterus to receive the
oocyte, which is now on its way down a fallopian
tube, where it might meet a nice young sperm.
The tubes are about 10 centimeters long, and
interestingly, they aren’t actually connected
to the ovaries. This means that when the egg
pushes through ovary, it has to float a short
way through the peritoneal cavity before it’s
caught by a fallopian tube.
Now, only if and when an egg fuses with a
sperm does it actually complete meiosis II
and officially become an ovum.
But, whether it’s fertilized or not, the
egg works its way down the tube until it enters
the uterus, a hollow, thick-walled, and very
stretchable muscular organ that sits anterior
to the rectum and posterosuperior to the bladder,
and ends with the cervix.
And the uterine wall is composed of three
layers: the perimetrium on the outside; the
bulky, smooth muscle myometrium that contracts
during labor; and the inner mucosal lining,
the endometrium, which consists of a thin,
deep basal layer, and an outer functional layer.
If fertilization does happen, then the new
embryo snuggles into the endometrium for gestation
-- but the uterus is only receptive to implantation
for a short time, about a week after ovulation.
If the egg isn’t fertilized, that outer,
functional layer sloughs off.
And that’s the first phase of the uterine,
or menstrual cycle -- the series of changes
that the endometrium goes through every 28
days or so, in response to changing hormone
levels, and in coordination with the ovarian
cycle.
The shedding of the functional layer is triggered
when the progesterone and estrogens that were
being produced by the corpus luteum start
to drop, about 10 days after ovulation. This
phase lasts about 5 days.
Meanwhile, the FSH and LH released from the
anterior pituitary start to rise again, stimulating
the next round of follicles, which begin to
make estrogen.
This heralds the start of phase two of the
menstrual cycle, the proliferative, or pre-ovulatory
phase, which typically lasts from days 6-14
of the cycle.
The rising estrogen levels in the follicles
stimulate the regeneration of the endometrium,
building a cushy, well-vascularized habitat
for another potential fertilized egg to call home.
And after the next egg is released, the final
secretory, or postovulatory phase begins.
This is when the ruptured follicle forms in
the corpus luteum. And if fertilization didn’t
happen, the corpus will stop producing progesterone,
and the endometrium will start to shed its
functional layer. And it starts all over again.
BUT! If, by this time, the egg has met a nice
sperm and gotten fertilized, then the pulse
of progesterone from the corpus triggers even
more thickening of the functional layer of
the endometrium, and a secretion of nutrients
that will tide an embryo over until it has
implanted itself in the blood-rich lining.
Which is a big if.
Like, its whole separate video “big.”
So that’s where we’re going next time!
But for now, you learned all about female
reproductive anatomy, how sex hormones affect
oogenesis and ovulation, and how the ovarian
and menstrual cycles mature and release oocytes,
and create a comfy uterine environment for
a fertilized egg.
Thank you to our Headmaster of Learning, Linnea
Boyev, and thank you to all of our Patreon
Patrons whose monthly contributions help make
Crash Course exist not only for themselves,
but for everyone, everywhere. If you like
Crash Course and want to help us keep making
videos like this one, you can go to patreon.com/crashcourse
This episode of Crash Course was filmed in
the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney Crash Course Studio.
It was written by Kathleen Yale, edited by
Blake de Pastino, and our consultant is Dr.
Brandon Jackson. It was directed by Nicholas
Jenkins, edited by Nicole Sweeney, our sound
designer is Michael Aranda, and the graphics
team is Thought Cafe.